angela is with us in idaho falls idaho
hi angela how can we help
hi i have a foundation and relationship
question
i mean i'm sorry you're going to speak
directly into your phone it was cutting
out on you
i have a financial and relationship uh
problem i'm hoping you guys can help me
solve it we'll try okay
so here's a bit of a back story um i was
all
married for almost 20 years we've been
divorced about two years
um i moved out about eight months ago
during the time when we were divorced
but living together
we were trying to work things out but it
didn't work out
we have financial issues with infidelity
that way
and relationship infidelity
we have decided we want to try to work
it out
where i'm currently seeing them my lease
is up and
i can't afford rents around here
on my own and so my ex has offered to
let me move back in from half of whether
i'd be paying at rent anywhere else
and is that okay to do while we're
trying to work things out or should we
stay
separated while we're still trying to
work things out
what are you still trying to figure out
after 20 years of divorce living
together after a divorce and then an
eight month
breakup what is there left to discuss
well
we have trust issues in each other yeah
clearly
so what do you what is gonna
what's gonna be what's gonna come to the
surface here
when you move back into his house and he
he is able to lord over you the fact
that you're paying less
less rent and you can't leave how is
that going to solve a trust issue
well see me moving out of this kind of
proven to him that you can't close that
boundary and there's no consequences
yeah see you're so that you're playing
russian roulette
um yeah i know this is hard i it sounds
like your relationship's over
and either he likes having you around
when it's convenient
and you are still hanging on to this
myth this fantasy that
it's one day gonna he's gonna bloom and
blossom and grow and he's gonna be the
guy you've always wanted to be
and after 20 years and a divorce
and eight months of giving it another go
it sounds like it's over
yeah well part of it for the future
which is
how to deal with the good we left and so
i i know listen listen you're just
accountable for that
it's just it's gonna be one thing after
another after another
and it has been so hard i know i don't
want to minimize it
it has been one thing after another
after another after another
and um i'm hearing somebody that doesn't
understand their innate value and worth
maybe i get told that by a few people
you are you are worth not being lied to
and cheated on
again and again you're worth not moving
into a house where someone's going to
say hey by the way i
i got you because i'm charging you half
rent
you're worth more than someone else's
table scraps
and you've locked yourself into if i
don't do this i can't live here and then
i can
man there is a big wide open country
lots of places you can go where people
are going to treat you with the value
that you're worth
and i know that's so hard to hear
yeah i guess it's more like maybe me
just
afraid of the change i guess because in
this eight months
where we have been apart i do come
almost
over almost every day um it's a bit
complicated
my brother lives with him yeah so i come
and i
see my brother and everything but so
you're not really divorced
no well yeah you've never really ended
the relationship your relationship is
continued yeah
and it's strung on dot dot and it went
from the main road to the gravel road
back to the main road
yeah it's just a mess yeah and if you
have a scab and you keep picking it and
you keep
bumping it um how old are you
39 you having children
um i have one adult child
and how old is your adult show 22
boy or girl boy okay
if he called you up and told you this
story
about him and his girlfriend
what would you tell him
i would tell him to break it off but
it's easier
yeah i said than done
why do you value him more than yourself
not your son your ex yeah
um i kind of feel responsible
i guess for him
and his relaxing because
that's so much issues we were having
before
i know i brought on issues i no i mean
that's just that's just bull crap
there's no possible there's no how in
the crud can you come up with the idea
that this guy cheating on you
you're responsible for it or him drugs
is your fault
that's not whacked it's not if your son
told you that about his girlfriend after
she's cheating and sleeping all over
town
and he still wants to hang on and he
said but it's my fault she sleeps around
you would smack him
wake up boy that's what you'd tell him
wouldn't you
yeah because he because you know your
son has value
well we know you have value and this is
just cray cray girl you need to get away
that's uncle dave talking i have no
psychological degrees dr john's got two
of them but
i'm telling you this i've got a problem
with your brother
yeah your brother doesn't need to be
buddying up with a guy who's
disrespected his sisters
over and over and over again for two
decades the way he has
if your brother had some courage he
would step out and y'all could get an
apartment together and figure this out
while you got your feet underneath you
but
he's not that guy yeah and he does help
me he actually my brother does give me
uh your brother stands there while you
walk back into this toxic relationship
i'm not talking about money look you
called and asked us what to do here's
what we're telling you to do get out
yeah
get away don't have any more contact
with this guy
at all he's your ex treat him like it
move on kiddo and am i missing something
no
yes the the other piece is treat
yourself
like somebody that treats yourself like
you
like you treat the people in your life
that you care about treat yourself at
least as good as your ex how about that
at least show yourself and and do the
work you've got to do
when someone is that kind of dude
someone's mistreating you and you
continually go back to them back to them
back to them back to them
over and over and over again and they
continue a pattern of misbehavior
it is because you don't care enough you
don't have enough self-respect to
walk away from crap and we're trying to
say
you are worth it you need to walk away
and you need to have zero contact with
this guy
if your brother wants to talk to you
it's gonna have to be somewhere else
where this guy's not around and not on
this property
you don't need to be on that property
ever again and you don't need to talk to
this guy
ever again ever period
you owe him nothing this is over
this is so toxic girl go you need to get
plugged into a good church you probably
need to move to a different city
yeah and start fresh make no mistake
you've been married to somebody for two
20 years at that point they're they're a
leg and an arm
it's a part of you this is gonna hurt
once you finally acknowledge this
thing's over
and you start the grieving process two
decades this is over over
it will hurt and hurt and hurt and that
doesn't mean it's wrong
that actually means you're doing the
hard work of cutting that infection
out and now you're going to be on the
road healing but you're done with you've
got to be done with it you got to be
done
like dave said don't go back it's over
you're worth more than this dr john
deloney just called your ex an infection
yep yeah and
your brother's not helping he's
certainly not helping
it's time to go get surgery connect
yourself with somebody who will see your
value
and i know it's hard that mirror gets
dusty and dirty sometimes it's hard to
see it
but man i i just hate hearing that in my
heart man yeah you need to get plugged
into a great church
i really think uncle dave's thinking you
need to move to a different city
and get a start because i think you're
going to have to have the physical
distance
to have the courage to stay away yeah
and have
have the discipline to stay away because
your healing's only going to begin to
the extent you stay awake kiddo you're
carrying in your heart his infidelity
his
drug use his fill in the blank his money
issues
man it's a mess you're worth more than
that baby it's a mess it's a mess it's a
mess you don't have to be mean to him
no you just don't have to be to him
you're already divorced it's over
yeah just you don't have to be it's not
you're not required anymore
your services are no longer needed
wow